Bis vor Kurzem
war ich der Meinung,
dass wir mehr Wissenschaftler*innen
in den Medien brauchen.
Mehr Stimmen der Vernunft!
Doch ... Corona hat
meine Meinung geändert.
Jetzt, wo mein Wunsch
in Erfüllung gegangen ist,
dass Wissenschaft
mehr Aufmerksamkeit bekommt,
muss ich einsehen: Ach, nee.
Denn Wissenschaftler
sind ja gar nicht automatisch
Stimmen der Vernunft.
Und wenn sie's nicht sind,
dann ist das
ein verdammt großes Problem.
Ein viel größeres Problem
als irgendeine Knalltüte,
die bei Telegram was von 'ner
Bill Gates-Verschwörung fantasiert.
Die Mehrheit der Bevölkerung weiß,
dass das 'ne Knalltüte ist.
Aber Wissenschaftler sind Experten,
auf deren Expertise die Mehrheit
der Bevölkerung vertraut.
Und Vertrauen
ist genau das richtige Wort,
denn wie kann ich als Laie
die Expertise
einer Expertin überprüfen?
Das muss sich ändern.
Holt euch Tee.
Erst mal
eine wichtige Unterscheidung:
Es gibt Wissenschaft
und es gibt Wissenschaftler.
Und das Problem
mit Wissenschaftlern ist:
Sie sind Menschen.
Ich hab nichts gegen Menschen, einige
meine besten Freunde sind Menschen.
Aber: Menschen können nie
zu 100 Prozent sachlich sein.
Du nicht, ich nicht.
Wir Menschen haben Meinungen,
politische Haltungen.
Menschen haben Ideologien.
Menschen haben ... wie heißt
dieses andere, unlogische Zeug?
Emotionen!
Man kann Menschen nicht trauen.
Ihr wisst, was ich meine:
Man kann sich nicht auf ihre
sachliche Korrektheit verlassen.
Genau deswegen gibt es
beim wissenschaftlichen Arbeiten
verschiedene Vorkehrungen,
damit Wissenschaft,
obwohl sie von Menschen
mit all ihren menschlichen Fehlern
durchgeführt wird,
so sachlich und verlässlich
wie möglich wird.
Was sind das für Vorkehrungen?
Zum Beispiel:
Wissenschaftlich arbeiten
heißt nicht nur Daten sammeln,
sondern auch
Kontrollprozesse einführen.
Zum Beispiel Kontrollexperimente,
Verblindung,
das Angeben von Fehlerbalken,
Schätzung statistischer Signifikanz.
Methoden machen eine Studie oft
besser oder schlechter.
Beispiel: Momentan
werden ja viele "Heilmittel"
gegen COVID-19 angeboten,
die angeblich
in "Studien" wirksam waren.
Nur, dass das "Studiendesign"
dann ungefähr so aussieht:
Wir haben 20 COVID-19-Infizierte,
am besten alles sonst
gesunde, junge Erwachsene,
täglich eine Stunde lang mit ...
Lauch abgeklopft.
Und siehe da, sie wurden
alle wieder gesund!
Das sagt gar nichts aus,
weil die meisten
gesunden Erwachsenen nach COVID-19
auch wieder gesund werden.
Abgesehen von
potenziellen Langzeitschäden,
aber da verweise ich auf unsere
"Quarks" fünf Minuten Corona-Folge.
Wenn aber jemand
eine Studie vorlegen kann,
weil nicht 20 sondern 2.000 COVID-19-
Infizierte untersucht wurden,
darunter auch Menschen
aus Risikogruppen
plus 2.000 Infizierte
einer Kontrollgruppe
mit derselben Demografie,
und die Testgruppe
mit Lauch abgeklopft wurde,
die Kontrollgruppe aber nur mit ...
Placebo-Lauch,
und die Testgruppe
dann statistisch signifikant
schneller oder öfter gesund wurde
als die Kontrollgruppe,
ja dann ...
kauft Lauch!
Mal ernst: Auch als Laie
sollte man immer versuchen,
wissenschaftliche Methoden
so gut es geht nachzuvollziehen,
um Wissenschaft einordnen zu können.
Wissenschaftliche Ergebnisse alleine
sagen meist wenig aus,
solange man die wissenschaftlichen
Methoden nicht kennt.
Wenn ich wollte,
könnte ich Multivitamin-Tabletten
beim DM kaufen,
die in andere Gläser umfüllen
und sie für
das zehnfache Geld als ...
Brain Booster-Pillen verkaufen.
Oder ich könnte
meinen Schweiß auffangen,
das Wasser verdunsten,
den Rest zu Tabletten pressen
und als
Brain Booster-Pillen verkaufen.
Es wär aber nicht so leicht,
irgendeine Schrottstudie,
so nach dem Lauch-Prinzip,
über diese Brain Booster-Pillen
zu veröffentlichen.
Ich könnt irgendwas
auf meiner Homepage veröffentlichen,
aber das ist keine anerkannte,
wissenschaftliche Veröffentlichung.
Wissenschaft ist erst legit,
wenn sie ordentlich
veröffentlicht ist.
Eine Veröffentlichung
muss das "Peer-Review" bestehen,
eine Überprüfung
durch andere Fachleute,
die in aller Regel Korrekturen
und Überarbeitungen fordern.
Was nicht überzeugen kann,
wird abgelehnt.
Das Peer-Review ist leider
kein perfekter Kontrollprozess.
Es werden, wie gesagt,
bessere und leider auch
schlechtere Studien veröffentlicht.
Nur nach der Veröffentlichung
geht der wissenschaftliche,
kritische Diskurs noch weiter.
Es kommt zum Beispiel vor,
dass Antwortartikel von Fachkollegen,
die irgendeiner Veröffentlichung
sachlich widersprechen,
im selben Journal
veröffentlicht werden.
Also, mit einem harten,
aber sachlichen Diskurs
wird in der Wissenschaft
viel offener umgegangen als anderswo,
was eben
zur Qualitätssicherung beiträgt.
Wie sagt man so schön:
Eine Studie ist keine Studie.
Als ich selbst
in der Forschung war,
hat mich oft frustriert,
wie unbedeutend man
als einzelne Wissenschaftlerin ist.
Auch nach jahrelanger,
intensiver Arbeit
ist so dein Beitrag
zur wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnis
noch nicht einmal ein kleines Rädchen
in 'nem großen Uhrwerk,
sondern nur so
ein Zähnchen auf 'nem Rädchen.
Oder sagen wir, nur ein Staubkorn
auf dem Zähnchen eines Rädchens
eines großen Uhrwerks.
Nur, dass das Uhrwerk
noch gar nicht läuft,
und die Uhr erst
erfunden werden muss.
Wissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse
setzen sich nun mal aus
vielen kleinen Puzzleteilen zusammen.
Es braucht in der Regel
viele verschiedene Studien,
viele verschiedene Forschungsgruppen
und viele Jahre,
bis sich
ein konsistentes Bild zusammensetzt.
Das ist einerseits anstrengend,
andererseits ist es auch gut,
dass eben nicht einzelne Autoritäten
ihre Meinung durchsetzen können,
sondern dass nur
die Gesamtdatenlage überzeugt.
Und dass verschiedene Ergebnisse auch
konsistent zusammenpassen müssen,
damit ein wissenschaftlicher Konsens
entsteht.
Das waren jetzt drei Gründe,
warum Wissenschaft verlässlich ist,
obwohl sie von Menschen gemacht wird.
Daraus leiten wir bei "maiLab"
Regeln für unsere Arbeit ab.
Wir erzählen nicht nur
von wissenschaftlichen Ergebnissen,
sondern machen auch nachvollziehbar,
wie Experten drauf gekommen sind.
Wir versuchen, uns auf peer-reviewte
Originalliteratur zu beziehen.
Wir versuchen,
möglichst viele Studien zu lesen.
Wir schauen uns auch sogenannte
"Literature Reviews" an,
die einen Überblick über verschiedene
Studien zum selben Thema geben.
Wir schauen nach:
Wo mehrere Studien
zu einer großen Auswertung
zusammen verarbeitet werden.
Und wir schauen auch nach:
von Forschungsgemeinschaften
oder Fachgesellschaften,
wo sich mehrere Expert*innen
auf eine Stellung geeinigt haben
und den geschlossen kommunizieren.
Klingt gut, oder?
Aber ihr,
die ihr "maiLab"-Video schaut,
müsstet eigentlich alle
unsere Quellen selbst durchlesen,
um zu überprüfen,
ob ich nicht Murks erzähle.
Was die meisten aber
stattdessen machen, ist:
Mir einfach vertrauen.
Oder grundsätzlich misstrauen.
Jetzt kommt das Verrückte:
Wir haben wenigstens noch Quellen
unter unseren Videos.
Aber wenn Wissenschaftler
im Fernsehen auftreten
oder Zeitungsinterviews geben,
sind meist keine Quellen angegeben,
weil die Expertin die Quelle ist.
Aber, wenn wir
ganz konsequent denken,
wissenschaftlich denken:
Warum sollten wir
Expertinnen oder Experten
in der Zeitung, im Fernsehen
einfach so vertrauen?
Typischerweise sind
Wissenschaftler so sachlich,
dass es fast schon nervt.
Hatten Sie eine gute Anreise?
Gut oder schlecht kann man
so pauschal nicht sagen.
Es gibt
ganz interessante Hinweise aus ...
Ich finde gar nicht,
dass bei den meisten Wissenschaftlern
die Sachlichkeit ein Problem ist,
sondern die Verständlichkeit.
Aber wenn Experten es mal nicht so
genau nehmen mit der Sachlichkeit,
kann das großen Schaden anrichten.
Denn wenn man Leute fragen würde:
Warum vertrauen Sie Wissenschaftlern,
wenn es um Wissenschaft geht?
Würden die meisten sagen: Weil das
die Experten sind, sich auskennen.
Dabei hat keiner der Punkte, die ich
im letzten Kapitel genannt habe,
mit Expertise zu tun, sondern
mit Kontrolle und Überprüfung.
Natürlich, die Expertise ist das,
was einen Experten überhaupt erst
zum Experten macht, keine Frage.
Nur Expertise ist keine Garantie
für Vertrauenswürdigkeit
oder Verlässlichkeit.
Es gibt verschiedene Gründe,
warum Experten
nicht automatisch korrekt sind.
Wir erinnern uns an das Problem:
Wissenschaftler sind Menschen.
Wissenschaftler können eitel sein
oder Rivalitäten untereinander haben.
Beispiel:
Im Zuge des berühmten Stromkriegs
gegen seinen Rivalen Nikola Tesla -
Gleichstrom versus Wechselstrom -
versuchte er,
die Menschen von seinem Gleichstrom
zu überzeugen,
indem er an streunenden Hunden
demonstrierte,
wie tödlich Wechselstrom doch sei.
Wissenschaftler können
politische Ideologien haben,
die ihre Sachlichkeit trüben.
Nobelpreisträger James Watson,
der die Struktur der DNA
mitentschlüsselte,
wurde später leider auch bekannt
für rassistische, antisemitische
und sexistische Statements,
die er teilweise auch
wissenschaftlich begründet.
Und Nobelpreisträger können
auch mal falsch liegen.
Chemienobelpreisträger Linus Pauling
war zum Beispiel davon überzeugt,
dass absurd hohe Dosen Vitamin C
nicht nur vor Erkältungen,
sondern sogar vor Krebs schützen.
Wie es wirklich ist:
Video in der Infocard.
Oder noch krasser:
Chemienobelpreisträger Kary Mullis
entwickelte die PCR-Technik,
auf der auch die Coronatest basieren,
war aber auch gleichzeitig
ein knallharter AIDS-Leugner.
Alter!
Und selbst wenn solche Fälle
eher selten sind,
können auch wenige verquere Experten
viel Schaden anrichten.
Denn wenn jetzt ein Nobelpreisträger
AIDS-Leugner ist,
dann hat irgendeine
Verschwörungsfantasie,
die vorher einfach
nur knalltütig war,
dann eine vermeintliche
wissenschaftliche Basis.
Während sich absurde Ideen in der
Wissenschaft nur schwer durchsetzen,
ist es in den Medien
eine ganz andere Geschichte.
Medien lieben alles,
was aus der Reihe tanzt.
Uns haben so viele Nachrichten
zu Sucharit Bhakdi erreicht.
der gerade mit seinem Expertenstatus
aber wissenschaftlich unhaltbaren
Falschaussagen viele Bücher verkauft.
Viele haben sich einen Faktencheck
gewünscht zu seinen Aussagen
oder zu seinem Buch
"Corona Fehlalarm",
das er zusammen mit seiner Ehefrau
Karina Reiss schrieb,
die Dermatologin ist an der Uni Kiel.
Ich werde mit wachsender Reichweite
dieses Kanals
auch zunehmend vorsichtiger,
wem ich diese Reichweite schenke.
Manche Aussagen oder Desinformationen
möchte man einfach nicht wiederholen,
einfach, um diesen Ideen nicht
noch mehr Aufmerksamkeit zu geben.
Aber da das Buch "Corona Fehlalarm",
'tschuldigung, "Corona-Fehlalarm?",
nur eine ganz offene Frage,
Spiegel-Bestseller ist
und damit ohnehin
sehr viel Aufmerksamkeit bekommt,
möchte ich die Gelegenheit nutzen,
Und die Aufmerksamkeit
auf die Uni Kiel lenken,
die etwas getan hat, was ich mir
von mehr Experten wünschen würde.
Nachdem die beiden Anfang August
den Kieler Nachrichten
ein Interview über ihr Buch gaben,
reagierte die Christian-Albrechts-
Universität zu Kiel
mit zwei Stellungnahmen,
in denen sie sich von ihrer eigenen
Professorin distanzierten.
Eine im Namen
der Hochschullehrer*innen
der medizinischen Fakultät,
unterzeichnet auf vom Dekan.
Und eine weitere
der Fachschaft Medizin.
Was die Kieler Mediziner hier tun,
ist das,
was man auch innerhalb der wissen-
schaftlichen Community tun würde:
Fehlerhafte Veröffentlichungen werden
zurückgezogen oder richtiggestellt.
Doch außerhalb
der wissenschaftlichen Community
gibt es solche Regeln nicht,
weil ... Meinungsfreiheit.
Ich hab nichts
gegen Meinungsfreiheit.
Einige meiner besten Freunde
haben Meinungsfreiheit.
Es geht mir nur nicht in den Kopf,
warum innerhalb der Wissenschaft
jede noch so kleine Ungenauigkeit
fünfmal hinterfragt wird,
aber wenn Professoren
diese Bubble verlassen
und an die breite Öffentlichkeit
treten, wird es nicht überprüft,
denn hier gilt ja Meinungsfreiheit.
Also Shoutout an die Uni Kiel,
die sich von ihrer
eigenen Professorin distanziert hat.
Von der Uni Mainz,
also Bhakdis Alma mater,
er vor seinem Ruhestand Professor für
Mikrobiologie an der Uniklinik Mainz,
hab ich nur diese Stellungnahme
gefunden.
Das war noch im März, da ging es
noch um seine Aussagen in Videos.
Yo, nur dass er halt als Bürger
wahrscheinlich
keinen Bestseller geschrieben hätte,
sondern eben nur als Professor.
Da ich das als eine sehr
schwache Distanzierung empfinde,
habe ich bei der Uni Mainz
nachgefragt, die erklärte:
Was in den meisten Fällen
auch nur richtig so ist.
Aber in machen Fällen gehört es
meiner Meinung nach
zu der Verantwortung von
wissenschaftlichen Institutionen,
Stellung zu beziehen, zum Beispiel,
wenn Falschinformationen
ein Massenpublikum erreichen.
Immerhin arbeitet die Uni Mainz
an einer sachlicheren Distanzierung.
Das ist gut und wichtig, find ich.
Denn ohne seinen Expertenstatus -
ehemaliger Professor der Uni Mainz -
hätte Bhakdi überhaupt nicht
den Einfluss, den er hat.
Und wir Journalisten müssen
besser darin werden,
vernünftigen Stimmen
mehr Aufmerksamkeit zu geben.
Denn wenn eine Uni eine Stellungnahme
rausbringt, aber es keiner liest,
dann sitzen Experten in Fernsehshows
oder mit Spiegel-Bestellern
am längeren Hebel.
Nicht nur Extremfälle
wie Reiss oder Bhakdi
schaden
der wissenschaftlichen Aufklärung.
Denn letztendlich richten Medien
so random Spotlights
auf einzelne Experten.
Und die große Mehrheit
der Wissenschaftler,
zum Beispiel
die große Mehrheit der Virologen,
traut sich gar nicht
in die Öffentlichkeit.
Die sind gar nicht sichtbar.
Dadurch haben einzelne Experten
sehr viel Einfluss.
Viele gehen damit verantwortungsvoll
um, aber wer garantiert uns,
dass nicht irgendein Experte
seine einzelne Meinung
als anerkannte Expertise verkauft?
Deshalb ist es so wichtig, dass
dieses kritische Qualitätsmanagement,
was innerhalb der wissenschaftlichen
Community betrieben wird,
auch in der
Wissenschaftskommunikation
an die breite Bevölkerung greift.
Wissenschaft beruht
nicht auf Vertrauen,
sondern auf Hinterfragen,
Kontrolle und auf Überprüfung.
Das ist das, was Wissenschaft
so verlässlich macht.
Solange in der
Wissenschaftskommunikation
nicht dieselben Standards an Sach-
lichkeit und Verlässlichkeit gelten
wie in der Wissenschaft selbst,
bringen mehr Wissenschaftler
in den Medien nicht mehr Aufklärung,
sondern mehr Verwirrung.
Das ist mir jedenfalls erst durch
Corona richtig klargeworden.
Mir ist noch nicht so ganz klar,
wie so eine Qualitätskontrolle
in der Wissenschaftskommunikation
sinnvoll geregelt aussehen könnte.
Vielleicht könnte man
eine Art Qualitätssiegel einführen.
oder so was wie eine Zulassung
für Wissenschaftskommunikatoren.
Vielleicht habt ihr Ideen für Regeln,
schreibt sie in die Kommentare.
In der Endcard muss ich euch
noch was Verrücktes erzählen.
Vielleicht ist euch aufgefallen, dass
dieses Video eine Woche zu spät kam,
eigentlich hätte es
schon letzte Woche kommen sollen,
aber letzte Woche war ich in Berlin.
Ich hab ein Bundesverdienstkreuz
bekommen.
Ich fühl mich so geehrt und alles ...
Wenn diese Endcard
sehr zerstückelt ist, liegt es daran,
dass ich nicht genau weiß,
was ich sagen soll,
was ich sagen kann,
was angemessen ist.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch noch mal
an alle anderen
Ordensträgerinnen und -träger,
schaut mal in die Videobeschreibung,
da findet ihr
ganz viele tolle Menschen,
die ich auch in Berlin mit
Sicherheitsabstand treffen durfte.
Ich hab mich auch mit den
Bundespräsidenten zusammengesetzt.
Wir haben ein kurzes Gespräch
über Wissenschaft
und Wissenschaftskommunikation
geführt,
unser Gespräch könnt ihr in der
Videobeschreibung anschauen.
Ansonsten:
Wir sehen uns nächste Woche,
bis dahin ... - Bleibt sicher!